[Music]
from Bryan Singer the director who
successfully launched the x-men left
when things got bad came back after
Matthew Vaughn fixed it and sort of tied
it all together comes the next
installment in the franchise and it's
bad again x-men apocalypse strap it in
for the sequel to the sequel of the
reboot prequel that continues the decade
huffing gimmick for no reason
welcome to the 80s as the timeline they
more or less sorted out in the last
movie completely craps the bed
featuring characters who have an aged a
day in 21 years characters who have 10
years before they look like Patrick
Stewart and characters where they just
said okay Hugh Jackman's gonna be in
this thing whether it makes sense or not
but there's one thing this movie makes
crystal-clear
Deadpool is all Fox has left I know
right forget what you know about the
x-men from the comics animated series or
previous movies because so did Brian
singer as Cyclops is a rebel for some
reason Psylocke is an evil bodyguard
everything all right
I'm fine setup angel is a Russian cage
fighter and mystique is the team leader
Wow wasn't she evil like one movie ago
get out of my head tall but hey at least
no one says do you believe named out
loud that's an x-men movie tradition
watch all your favorite x-men gather
together in the background of another
mystique movie haha the villain who was
proud of her blue skin is back and now
her character is the exact opposite
because Jennifer Lawrence is super
famous and she's really tired of sitting
in makeup for hours on end you not blue
but she's not the only blue mutant with
better things to do Oscar Isaacs
apocalypse has arrived and he looks
terrible thrill at his plan to become
immortal by using the plot of the movie
cocoon while gathering the four
strongest mutants of his age or just
whoever he happens to bump into as he
unleashes his powers of learning
disintegrating people with a single
thought and never using that power again
hmm for a guy out to cleanse the world
you think he tried that move more than
once stop standing around and melt them
up with your magics and already ride a
law on this epic story of apocalypse
trying to conquer the world and the
x-men trying to stop it and that well
that's that's it that's that's the whole
pot right there
so if you love the x-men movies get
ready because this one is going through
all the obligatory motions with another
will bring origin another quick silver
sequins another aborted Phoenix saga and
the old standby Charles and Erik being
friends becoming enemies and becoming
friends again what do you know wake up
to when you wake up laughter the
graceful swell Oh pity for the poor soul
who comes to that school looking for a
home uh Charles your buddy there killed
like millions of people as time maybe
pick a new frenemy starring Ross and
Rachel slumber games blue-on-blue
violins all filler no thriller the opera
singer from The Fifth Element kid did
sansa soy line negasonic teenage
featured extras and it's
getting old man Logan x-men Genesis well
at least we can all agree that third
one's always the worst congratulations
you played yourself be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers I have a pen I
have an apple Oh Apple pen orange
gorilla slippers how can I teach these
kids
and that's no mood it's the Deathstar
put K so in my face ohh